is this the real life  Amidala place is this just fantasy  in the landslide no escape from reality  I want a simple task force of the most  dangerous people on the planet they're  bad guys worst of the worst  was this a cheerleading tryouts  ah hi boys  good shot guy shoots people he's  crocodile he eats people burns people  you're possessed by witch she's just  crazy what was that I should kill  everyone in escape sorry  the voices I'm kidding  that's not what they really said this is  the deal you're going somewhere very bad  do something don't get killed so save  the world  I can't wait to show you my toys  let's do something fun  you  seriously the hell's wrong with you  people for bad guys it's what we do